has been and thanks to the organizers
for the opportunity to present my group
stock so we had a complex networks lab
or in other words we do network science
these are my PhD students and my
undergrads and things have White's
changed since the picture was taken
about a year ago boys currently PhD
student at Stanford who is going to
start her PhD or actually graduate
studies I'm not sure yet if masters or
PhD program at MIT jen is going to
Silicon Valley and I hired for new
undergrads because I had fantastic
experience publishing with them they're
just very very ambitious kids of the
grad students lay in fossil and URI are
all going to be done in next two months
and they're going to Google Microsoft
and Facebook so despite our doing bio
research social networking companies
seem to be very interested in what we do
these are the funding agencies and most
of the work I a fund my group and most
of the work I'll be talking about today
has been funded by NSF we study networks
we do anything and everything with
networks in many domains but most of the
computational problems we are dealing
with our motivated by problems in by
domain and we study these hairballs
meaning any omics data that can be
modeled as a network or integrating
multiple omics data into a network and
studying the structure of the network
the patterns of interconnectivity and
trying from this to learn something
about cellular functioning in one of the
cell or cellular process we are very
interested in is to study human aging
there's three reasons number one we all
want to live longer happier healthier
lives number two MA NSF will not fund
disease but they will fund aging as a
computational scientist that's very
important to get funding from an NSF NIH
funds both study of aging and disease as
many other things and three it's a
dynamic biological process which enables
me to model cell as a dynamical system
and then do dynamic network analysis a
computational problem I'm personally
very interested in so why do we
currently know about human aging gen age
I don't know how familiar are with aging
and I was until maybe five years ago
other than we all do agent Jen each
contains about 260 genes in human that
have been implicated in aging of those
three have been implicated in aging
experimentally the rest come from
computational analysis reason is why we
can study human aging experimentally we
live very long time and there's lots of
ethical constraints so what people
typically do these are all computational
and statistical analysis many we might
not think of genomic sequence alignment
as a computational strategy it is
nothing but computational prediction so
toe tip achill strategies are collect
expression data in human at different
ages these measurements typically come
from different individuals and then if a
jeans expression significantly changes
with age the genes implicated to be
aging-related aging-related can mean two
things promote longevity which is very
good or causes premature aging which is
what we want to avoid so being
implicated in aging is not necessarily a
bad thing second model species such as
east fruit fly worm in those pieces you
can study aging experimentally for lack
of those two key constraints and then
you can transfer knowledge from
experimentally determined aging lady
Genia model species to a sequence
similar gene in human through genomic
sequence alignment what's the key
drawback of these both of these types of
approaches there's very many approaches
within each of these I'm just giving you
high level idea how this is done but the
key disadvantages they're all ignoring
in interconnectivity between genes
proteins gene products so for the
purpose of my talk I will be using
terminology gene and protein is the same
thing biologists please don't hate me um
so two key ideas we've been working on
in the context of studying aging is
let's pretend me we're in a perfect
world will we have biological networks
at different ages just as we can measure
gene expression data we don't have such
experimental data due to limitations of
bio technologies but we have static
network data and dynamic gene expression
beta maybe we were lucky that for some
processes we had protein
this data which we are still no they're
not there yet but can we combine the two
data types to infer these age specific
networks and then analogous to what is
none from gene expression data alone
from the combined network in gene
expression data can be predicted
aging-related those genes whose network
transitions significantly change with
age second can redefine the note can we
redefine the notion of sequence homology
to network homology through the notional
network alignment by trying to find
we've heard about enter client from man
but trying to find network similar
regions between molecular networks of
different species so lined improperly
rather than miss aligning the edges and
if so can we analogously transfer
experimental aging-related knowledge
from model species to human between
conserved network rather than sequence
reaches we've done lots of efforts on
both in my talk I'll primarily focus on
forgive me one second please
I will in my talk primarily focus
technical issues I apologize on the
topic of dynamic network analysis in the
interest of time my goal is to tell you
what we do why we do it and give you a
conceptual idea high-level overview how
we do it there will be zillion questions
I'm sure you will find lots of drawbacks
I'm sure feel free to ask me throughout
the talk or after during the Q&A and I
will briefly maybe devote one minute if
we have time to this topic just giving
you some keywords and pointing to some
of the references if this interest you
so you can check it out on your own so
if this is the current static of course
it's the story to example or aesthetic
representation of the cell whatever
later we currently have well maybe not
all genes are active I'll tell you a
little bit what it means super expressed
relevant for the given time age
condition tissue of interest maybe we
are only interested in the subset of the
jeans and some subset or all of the
interactions between those jeans this is
kind of relevant to this regulated
pathways if you really want to think
about it but we are more interested in a
temporal aspect of inferring networks
corresponding to different times and
then studying evolution of network
structure from global local whichever
perspective you would like to do now in
the real life we don't have such data
but we've heard a lot in this particular
workshop by people who are actually in
the audience what about data integration
as well as it's been recognized that
dynamic network analysis is needed to
better model cellular functioning and in
particular the two are not distinct
ideas they're actually quite related a
networking integration to achieve
network dynamics so what we do is let me
try to see what I can do with my laser
filter the laser is working into the
slide changement does it so it's causing
me some issues
okay so what we do to first in fergus
networks and that was not a key concept
the key goal of our project go was just
to use a proof of strata a proof of
concept strategy to do so but what we do
to infer networks and then what we do to
analyze them to study human aging and
deepen our knowledge about human aging
compared to traditional gene expression
and sequence based analysis okay so we
are dealing with aesthetic
protein-protein interaction networks we
are using PPI data is a proof of concept
you can feel free to replace with any
other type of data that you would like
we base our study on HP rd data as well
as binary data separately to make sure
our approach is robust to the choice of
the ppi network data we then study
combined the static network with a
aging-related gene expression data in
this case we were first dealing with
microarray data and then Revere
suggested why not try RNA sec maybe you
get different predictions maybe you get
similar ones we actually have a
significant overlap between predictions
that we get independent of which of
these two data sets Rios majority of the
results every report are for using this
particular gene expression data we have
37 ages multiple individuals per age and
multiple samples per individual and this
data allows us to compute for each age
the eat for each gene its detection
p-value which is related to the overall
abundance of its mrna in the given age
and we have a way to based on these p
values keep genes only genes that are
active in a given age and keep
interactions between those jeans so
initially we kept all the interactions
between the genes in the network later
on we had a follow-up study where we
removed some of the non-redundant
irrelevant non-central not important how
everyone call it edges are not going to
go into details there if you would like
to know more please follow up with me
both strategies produce meaningful
predictions and actually removing some
of the interactions to make the
network's parser so getting rid of the
irrelevant pages helps the process of
network interest and
here's just association of 37 networks
that have between these many nodes and
these many interactions mm-hmm now
enhance at least to be moving proteins
because they are not expressed was less
powerful than 3 waiting the edges so
have you tried it to me wait the edges
based on the expression rather than
simply we have not combined in the
process of improving edges expression on
top of the ppi did lots of ideas we've
heard here through the process of
natural propagation or error or
diffusion you can use for that purpose
and that's definitely something we are
exploring but we are very interested not
just to do propagation here and
propagation here and propagation here
i'm using propagation is just again
proof of concept we are very interested
to consider interactions between these
different networks at different ages
somehow and we had no idea at how so
that's definitely currently funded idea
again this is just the proof of contact
and for applied scientists who typically
use arbitrary network inference method
in particular this study focuses on
constructing drink or expression
networks and arbiter such as pearson
correlation and arbitrary cutoff what is
vs is not we have a study that says how
you the choice of the network inference
method directly affects what biological
question or questions you might be able
to answer with the resulting networks so
this is definitely a valid point and i
doubt that there will be approached
networking france approach that will
work for every possible application the
best so you definitely want to target
whatever question you're asking
the genes that are specifically
expressed at that age so the question is
the way i th keep genes that are
specifically expressed at that page can
you define what you mean by specifically
okay so in in a given age we find
computer detection p value of each gene
at that age it's computed as intensity
value of the perfect match probe of the
given gene has to be significantly
higher than the intensity value of the
mismatch probe for the given gene now
it's within a sample this is adopted a
widely adopted strategy especially by
the authors of the paper who gene
expression data we used we are not
qualified to make such judgments on my
own so we used for both microwave and
RNA sec data two different strategies we
used how to define what the inactive
gene is guided by the authors of the
paper I'm sorry this is for brain tissue
because this gene expression data in
both are for brain tissue probably start
typically studied really otherwise you
get very few ages very few samples
bridge so you don't have enough
statistical power so that's until
there's some bias in which predictions
we make they might be actually biased
towards brain we we remove the genes we
don't don't need a cut-off and remove
all of the interactions but we keep all
edges between the active genes and
there's a way to get rid of some of them
and I definitely think we should be
keeping some genes that are not active
because they might be critically
connected active network parts so we are
aware that of lots of room for
improvement there mm-hmm see patients
and defend at times no it's different
patients that's the limitation of why we
are not able like people the original
dataset Lucas relative same people
perhaps twice could be normalized
in a sibling day these are all
postmortem they thought that you collect
so it's we are limited with even with
collecting data from different
individuals we are very limited what we
what we can collect yes hence the need
to do something computationally about
human aging in general okay so first
thing we're there it is okay does global
network topology of the age i will call
these age specific networks we had 37 of
them do their global network properties
change we did lots of trust needs to
just three kind of key findings with
lots of comprehensive analysis and our
general finding is no matter what we did
general topology does not change which i
guess is good the cell does not
completely disconnect or die as we age
but we were wondering what might be
happening so we zoomed into the local
level around the genes and when I say
local I don't mean direct neighborhood I
don't mean even third neighborhood
around the gene I mean whichever
property you use to define network
position of a node by local I mean we
are focusing on property or the node
within a network but property of a node
can be made character is mathematically
virtually by an infinite number of
options we use seven such properties
which are called note centrality is that
basically tell you whether I know this
peripheral or not and they are quite
different where we will show you how
complementary they are there different
mathematical notions that capture
different level of peripheral peripheral
to your centrality don't think about
what it means for not to be central in
the network in 3d or 2d visual space
really this is math we're relying so for
each node in each age we compute its
centrality for a given centrality value
and then we try to analyze how these
time series of the results changes with
age is there any signal that the signal
that is interesting or not of course in
the process we compute statistical
significance of correlation with age I'm
intentionally using quotes because I
don't want to go into more details what
we do there and just to give you an
intuition if this is three different
networks a different a at different
times or different ages
no they're positioned exactly where they
are in each network into this pace if
you focus on this particular node it
loses connectivity is captured by degree
with age so that would be an indication
that Network position of these note
changes with age and we would predict it
as aging-related degrees just of course
a cartoon illustration of what we do we
use a lot more constraining properties
and we use seven of them between us
closeness clustering coefficient degree
is interesting the graph a degree and
cake or distant relatives and for each
of the centrality to show you how many
of genes we identify whose network
position significantly change with age
the most of the one that captures the
most genes is the graphic based measure
that I developed together with Natasha
and other collaborators back in 2011 and
fYI at that time we showed that this
particular measure beats a propagation
based measure based on random walks
called estrada index or subject
centrality so I know there's been lots
of discussions of a propagation based
ideas I think the hypothesis behind it
is great there could be some alternative
solutions to the problem question
question in the original data disease
with I know those people starting things
like all Sun where is it this was not
biased towards any disease but when we
validate the predictions we make we will
go to list of brain related it is to my
knowledge yes they were they were
healthy or at least based on the related
so I I don't think that any of the two
data sets were biased towards the
disease this is the union of all the
predictions and this particular measure
that happens to be ours captures almost
all of the predictions are that are
captured by all other centrality is now
for network scientists i want to show
you an interesting finding without
spending too much time on it this is the
number of old of the predictions that
were that were supported by at least
once exactly one centrality exactly two
central t's exactly three four five six
seven very few predictions were
supported by multiple centrality which
means all of these seven different
mathematical notions are quite
complementary to each other so next time
if your applied scientist and you want
to just use a centrality measure think
twice which one you choose because we
might get complete
the difference at the results and the
next question is okay we have five point
seven of old jeans 500 something 37 of
them total who better identified by at
least one centrality is aging-related in
terms of networks so how do we validate
them in addition to at every step
measuring statistical significance of
the prediction we compute statistical
significance of the whole approach by
randomizing the data running approach
random data and making sure we cannot be
at the same result by chance and then we
do something that is typically done in
the biometrics community can we find
some of our predictions in independent
data say that we have not used in the
process of making predictions though
they share functional in disease
overlaps with known aging-related genes
and also are they enriched in aging
related processes and diseases and
finally for some not all predictions
that you really can't find anywhere else
can we find them in the very recent
literature and try to validate them that
way I will quickly guide you through
some of the results here these are four
sets of independent known run through
the aging relations I'm saying known in
quotes because remember they're all
predictions from gene expression or
sequence analysis I'm actually lying to
you in the first in the first case this
is the same gene expression data diffuse
I don't know if this is visible in terms
of color there's two colors here darker
and lighter darker and lighter and then
this is the percentage of the genes that
are in the ground through data sets in
four three out of four of them their
significant overlap why am i showing you
this even though we used it to produce
predictions there's hundred plus
predictions that can't be captured by
gene expression data alone when we add
the data to the network we can catch
from other predictions with the
systematic analysis of go terms I want
to show you some cherry-picked examples
that illustrate a point well our
predictions are enriched in cell aging
and these are examples of for Disease
ontology terms that are known to be
related for example known aging related
genes are also emission m and there's
article supporting links of these
diseases to aging sick diseases were
enriched in our predictions we call them
tiny change that were missed by any
grant through data
and then we went to the literature and
try to see whether we can link some of
those diseases to aging and 45 of them
we were able to do so which is
additional encouraging results that our
predictions might be complimenting
aging-related knowledge that is already
out there and finally when it comes to
not all predictions about hundreds of
them were not found hundreds of our
patients were not found in any existing
at least those that we explored
aging-related data sources we pick top
10 of them we have a way of scoring
predictions based on how many centrality
support the prediction and the p value
of the significance of the correlation
with age and eight of them we managed to
find a direct or indirect for each of
them we managed to find director in
direct link to aging in the literature
here is paraphrase phrases and the
family needs of the corresponding
articles very briefly haha question I am
more than happy they're all all the data
is publicly available I'm happy whoever
is doing this experience Lee to test it
I'm currently well I've been in
discussion with buck Institute for aging
which is actually here close to San
Francisco of trying to see what we can
do with our predictions or take their
data make new predictions and maybe that
there will be more interested that way
so that's an ex call definitely to
experimentally build eight some of these
predictions these are not based on GX
yes but do an expression is a part of
the prediction process but particular
gene expression data set and these are
not find in gene expression that we used
or any other gene expression data that
we explore or sequence-based predictions
knocking out our expression is well they
might not have sequence homologues in
other species and maybe they are not
supported by gene expression but maybe
networks though that's exactly the
hypothesis I'm sure we can dig out some
examples that experimentalist would be
interested in there is a slide I was
just curious oh this is fun gene this is
how it's called in the day the gene
these names really don't mean anything
to me as a computational scientist
that's exactly how they're called in HP
rd database yeah we provide online a
unique gene IDs for each of these so
that you avoid the bias of translating
between different databases yeah okay so
I'll try to give you a quick overview of
another methodology the first thing is
proof of concept of dynamic net analysis
actually can be very useful to study
human aging here we introduce the
nominal methodology that's established
in a vet's based on a very
well-established idea of static reflets
the bottom the motivation was we compute
property of a node in this sub network
in this age the Civic network and in
this one and in this one and then we
study time series of the results but we
really ignore any into really enter any
relationship at the interface between
these different networks so can we
define the network property that spans
multiple snapshots in this case we are
dealing with grassroots I'll show you a
little more detailed examples by signing
temporal order of events on top of the
static edges that we have so we are not
no longer dealing with static graphics
these three no.10 spans multiple
snapshots and to actually industry node
triangle spends three Snatchers in this
example just to give you a little bit of
formal idea what we are talking about
just aesthetic reference and these are
opposite
grafton up to four nodes are equivalence
classes of isomorphic connected subgraph
then demographics we define them and its
equivalence classes of isomorphic delta
T connected sub reps where delta T
connected means between every pair of
nodes an ordered pair of nodes there is
a delta T time respecting path between
the two now between the two nodes and
what that means is for any consecutive
pair of events along the path such as
Monday and Tuesday Tuesday and Wednesday
or if I had riding saturday or saturday
and sunday there can be at most date
delta T time between those two events
before they are considered delta T
adjacent so there's lots of formal
definitions we introduced in the paper
but bottom line is in both of these
examples monday tuesday wednesday friday
saturday sunday if my delta T is one day
this will be my resulting dynamic
griflet again 1 2 3 corresponds to
temporal order of edges in which they
occur if I hang monday tuesday thursday
what does my delta T need to be so I
have one two and three because Jews
enter their two days apart my delta T
now has would have to be two days if I
had Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday no
problem we allow multiple events over to
say match and here are this is the same
example I already showed you need rest
of challengers going to speed it up this
is the general idea here are all
possible dynamic reflects on up to three
events we already miss the number of
events and in this case up to four nodes
okay in when we when we do computations
in graphs we go up to six nodes and up
to seven events and you will see that
there is multiple dynamic rattles that
correspond to the same static method if
you ignore the temporal dimension on the
edges so we had to deal with lots of
lots of not problems research questions
how many graduates are there with n
nodes and kaydence dynamic graph let's
weave purdy write a recursive formula
and then found the closed form solution
and then once you know what you need to
count how we actually counted in the
network we have two ways of doing it I'm
not going to go into details in the
interest of time but the outputs of this
methodology is either for the whole
network when
for the whole dynamic network how many
graduates of each type how many dynamic
graphs which type appear in the network
or for each node how many dynamic
reflets and not participates in this is
the concept of graduate degree vector of
a node with respect to dynamic graphics
and we do take into account automatisms
orbits when we do this i'm going to show
you ten percent of the evaluation part
of this paper and be very close to
concluding my talk when we use so what
if you consider static ppi network and
try to use graphics to make predictions
we are calling those tetas kravitz what
we've done before because we are using
setting reference in each particular
snapshots without any relationship
between snapshots we are referring to
better analysis aesthetic temporal graph
let's and dynamic reference are those
that span multiple snapshots as one at
once and we are here trying to hide the
knowledge about the given known Adrienne
value gene and measuring how accurate we
are in predicting it so i'm showing you
kind of precision equivalent of this
analysis you can see statistics for
random predictions static already is
better than random order magnitude elin
static temporal look how much it
improves compared to static analysis so
next time you do static analysis of the
self think how much you can improve
doing something dynamically although
it's not fair these two are not fair to
static lonely because they do include
gene expression data which static does
not and then dynamic actually improves
drastically again it might not seem
drastic it statistically significant
improvement and when we try to go to
novel predictions by each approach and
try to validate them against
sequence-based predictions this is
equivalent of gin age the most trusted
source of aging related data in human
out there only dynamic graphs produce
statistically significant functional and
disease overlap with the known genes in
the interest of time I'm going to skip
examples of go in terms and by end all
terms that we found a deter novel to
dynamic graffle based predictions that
we managed to validate in the literature
and this is over also comparison of the
different types of gravity approaches
where dynamic are superior in two-thirds
on all cases and comparable interesting
so static analysis is definitely let me
start with this and dynamic analysis is
definitely better than static temporal
which is definitely better than static
and we can use dynamic gratis to
characterize the structure of the entire
network or individual notes static
methods have been used in very many
computational and applies tasks there is
no reason why it can do the same with
dynamic graphs and code is available
online just I'll take 30 seconds to tell
you some key comments on network
alignment without telling you what we do
or how we have a new method for
parametric alignment magna is definitely
the methodology but we improved it with
lots of other features user
user-friendly graphical interface into
magna plus plus and recently we extended
this to multiple network alignment and
the new paper is an archived although
not published yet mobile network
alignment in egg have used it for the
purpose of aging I want to point anybody
who works on the topical Network
alignment especially global one read
this paper even today I'm reading papers
and they are not failed evaluating their
method against existing ones for a very
simple reason but definitely please read
and this is our recent survey on the
topic I already acknowledged most of my
group just let me mention that fossil
was the one working on the first study
of studying dynamic aging through
dynamic networks and then we the topic
of dynamic graphics was done by yuri and
hui li and NSF Air Force Google and NIH
are the groups or agencies that are
funding my group I'll be happy to take
any questions thank you
speculator underlying mechanism like
just take a gene and accept alipay is
changing with age what is going on that
can be decoupled from changes in gene
expression alone we've been asked this
question the short version is I don't
know long version is networks might be
capturing different things than
expression data it could be that
networks especially the measures we use
go even beyond the neighbors to
neighbors to their neighbors and graph
let's go like back for around the given
node I'm not going to go into details
why and all around it and given small
world nature of real world networks that
might be capturing the entire network so
it's simply capturing in direct
relationships I don't know but I have
some ideas but I really can't even if
they might be completely wrong so I
would prefer not to discuss in detail
i'm just gonna say power of networks
this science generalization
Oh
we should not we have seen lots of work
in social network research about dynamic
motifs but they are defining dynamic
motifs with respect to random graph
models so we were not aware of that work
and yeah so the answer is no but
definitely something we will take a look
into it but is it is essential to have
I can reduce the same I
you are adding only in with labels on
edges as we currently have we know the
order of labels it's extremely important
because if you don't know the order of
labels and you increase the number of
labels you will get exponentially huge
number of graphics that you can't even
deal with so that's completely different
problem people have tried to address it
and wait for labels on up to identify
there's millions of options so it just
there's way too many options so it's a
great question and I would like to come
up with a way to solve the problem that
way but it's not directly applicable
let's thank tiana are getting here